the one thing that was constant is that
we care about each other you know and
that we've been through stuff together
and I and I take a lot of pride in that
that I have that with a lot of my
clients you know it's like
Ariana Grande's a client but we went
through Manchester
that's my experience together like those
kind of things bring you together with
people and were you there uh no I was
actually meeting her in London the next
city and then so I met her and we got
her to Boca and then we met and then
we we were there for three days and then
we talked and then the courage to go
back to Manchester and do that show and
say look we're going to answer this
um and I was there when she met with the
families one by one
um which was
Brave and hard and those families are
incredible that city is incredible the
fact that they showed up the way they
did
um but whether it be that or other
people just I remember watching um
what's it called the documentary on uh
oh God now I'm I'm in a brain fart um um
what's it um the British singer she
passed away oh uh what's her name Amy
Winehouse Amy Winehouse yeah and I
remember watching that and the manager
goes it wasn't my responsibility to take
care of it was just my responsibility to
manage her career or get her on stage I
think he said I felt like the father was
the same way and but I was I was
infuriated I wanted to like reach
through and like punch the dude in the
face because I'm like
no one expects you to get everything
right but you gotta try and care about
people you know and
I mean what's it all for you know well a
lot of people would say well you know
it's you you start off this conversation
that we were having today as being the
entrepreneurial Spirit doesn't always
align with your heart you know unless
your heart's there for the money so like
even you talk about the Amy Winehouse
documentary I was more I wanted to reach
through the camera and and and strangle
the father more than look yeah because
he does have you know I don't expect my
manager it happens to be my best friend
who I grew up with Michael Rosenberg it
was like a brother to me but I know that
ultimately or mostly people are you know
these are business deals
[Music]